some idea of what the news that is
coming of about the testimony from fowey
the president's said that frankly the
situation ok Falchi will testify in the
Senate the Democrats should be his
ashamed he said he referenced the house
as a bunch of Trump haters so it sounds
like that is where we are learning about
this testimony of dr. pouchy in the
Senate as we wait to hear from the
president in his own words this would
certainly be a big moment in the middle
of this pandemic to hear from the lead
infectious disease expert that has been
advising the president Chris Wright it's
a big moment for the president to he's
making his first who's going out to a
swing state for one of these kind of
visits that pence tried out last week he
is going to go will he wear a mask who's
wearing a mask
how's it going and again Arizona is a
swing state in a place where we are
watching this closely and there has been
a lot of tension between the people who
were angry about the lockdown and people
who were concerned about this illness
and the president's flying out he's
flying right into the middle of that and
this is all part of an administration
that's trying to pitch forward pivot
forward into reopening and away from
having to talk all the time about the
sickness and its containment as far as
the concerns about the people traveling
with him he also is talking and taking
questions on that everyone traveling
with him and around him has been tested
all right we will hear from the
president in a short time from now Crist
our Walt great to be with you this
morning